one goal is to get my kids to believe in  themselves  [Music]  every friday on our agenda i said 3 30  celebrations  [Music]  whether it's word lists that are  mastered whether it's our multiplication  that we're gonna find something to  celebrate  [Music]  the kids master these skills they earn  these points they show proficiency with  the standards  learning happens  [Music]  even if you are a struggling kid  every point every second a video that  you watch every effort that you make all  goes to a class total right so everybody  in their struggles gets to participate  when we got those 10 million points i  had to have a girl uh hold the camera  and i had balloons filled with confetti  and so i'm going around popping these  balloons but she's holding my phone and  she's like you know it's like taking  this selfie in an earthquake kind of  thing so  when you just see this classroom like  come together and like unite among that  it's just it's awesome  [Music]